You've already seen what the graph of x cubed looks like. So if we made the
coefficient at the front of the term 3 instead of 1 but keep it positive the
overall behavior will still be the same. It's still going to start low on the
left and reach up way high on the right. Since 5 x to the 4th times x squared
has an even degree. We know that the left and right side are going to point in
the same direction. Since the leading coefficient is positive it's going to
start way up high on the left hand side. And then also rise up high on the
right hand side. For this function with a negative 2 x to the 5th, since the
degree is odd the ends are going to point in opposite directions. And since
this leading coefficient is negative, it's going to start up high on the left,
and reach way down low on the right.